And now I'm going to be really demanding.
I would like to know what is the variance of the mean, not the sum, but the mean.
I'm going to put 1/N over here--the same sum as before.
This is what you do, for example, when you compute the mean outcome of an election from a sample
of size N. You take the sum of the things you saw and you compute the mean.
That's the formula of the mean, but now I'm asking what's the variance of the mean.
So I'm not asking for this one over here--we asking for this one over here.
And as a hint, at some point we talked about something like the following--
what if you multiple a variable by a constant A, what happens to its variance?
It was something times variance X.
Let's do the first. What goes in there.